what is the best thing about Governor
Scott won the best thing about Governor
Scott Walker is that he comes from
central casting which is actually a
place it in Hollywood yeah that's about
the couple's locks I mean has a
compelling life story he's at Midwestern
governor uh you know he had an in
enormously popular among conservatives
fight with the unions um a lot of early
money is fought to him you know he's
good-looking guy good-looking family
just seems like the right type of
candidate that Republicans can get
behind Republicans tend to elect the
most electable conservative candidate it
would seem that that he fits right in
there I guess the counter-argument to
that might be well wasn't that Mitt
Romney that wasn't Romney band but the
thing that people the the difference is
that people knew something about marami
the one thing that people knew about me
Romney was that you know he was not a
touch businessman and Walker doesn't
really have that baggage at all I mean
that's know that and that's to his
benefit I mean they were break Romney
superficially they have the same resume
the similar resume uh but the Romney had
baggage that Scott Walker doesn't know
yet do you think some of these things
that you're saying are exactly you think
some of these things that you're saying
are positive attributes for him actually
hurt him like just the idea that he's
just sort of a middle-aged white guy
normal family etc the back kind of thing
it's not what excites people doesn't
mean you're a bad politician and maybe
the base likes a lot of the union stuff
and all that but just that there's there
doesn't seem to be a lot of an
excitement factor with this guy right
you know we've seen with with uh with
candidate Barack Obama how in the right
hands have an unknown a blank slate you
can be the canvas on which a beautiful
painting is constructed so you know you
could cut other way the worst thing
about Scott Walker is that there is not
one thing that people know about it you
know it's it's it's a potential strength
but i think it's the biggest weakness
which is that he is not just an unknown
but what is he is he a gut to see a
union the guy who busted the union state
employees unions is he the evangelical
who is he what is he in a way is that
the best thing that a candidate could
have because then it's like as the
primaries go along it's like you get to
define you're in the hands yeah of a
town
Alton team advisors and in the in the
mind of someone with natural political
skills yes but scott Walker's political
skills very very rusty he's had a very
rough going anytime you sort of
interacting with the media to the point
where all he complains about now is well
you can't ask me that question why you
ask me that question every question is
on the table the earlier you start
complaining about the questions that the
media and i know republicans do it to
game people just like in the media but
you can't do that you got to figure out
a way to answer questions newt gingrich
can do it newt gingrich yeah just Scott
Walker needs to study Newt Gingrich used
to study the way he talked the way he
you know the way he listened to people
his answers and needs to emulate Newt
Gingrich I think the other perception
about Scott Walker that kind of goes
with that and this is this is the
biggest potential problem he is not a
dumb guy but you make a certain number
of mistakes that you know individually
we would all do in different ways thay
add up to a perception and if that
becomes the perception that he's kind of
dull and he's like the Rick Perry read
this race is gonna say the Dan Quayle
the Danville bit more Rick Perry just
like a you know xperia guys pretty good
at being governor uh but boy subjecting
any sort of national security question
and it's just like you're you know
you're asked the same thing the
three-year-old can't have that be the
one thing that people know about you so
he has to get up to he's been studying
spend a lot of time see this this I
don't understand this if your candidate
is studying issues you know healthy but
you're kind of it is studying issues
yeah he's brushing up at night no no no
you you show him conversing you keep him
away from the press and let him study
but don't tell people your studies yeah
the people around I'm not really I don't
know I'm not too impressed by the
quality of people that he has giving him
advice these days yeah you gotta fake it
till you make it right right you know
and you don't tell people you're faking
hi I'm faking this now i'll be making it
soon that's this is that how it works
that's not how i thought that's how it
works i guess what works in my business
but i don't think it works and you're
not running for analysis yeah maybe or i
don't know anyway Scott Walker what do
you think is the idea that people don't
know that much about him can happy used
to his advantage or is it a disadvantage
and does he have the right people around
him to sort of shake that image let us
know your thoughts in the comments right